what did you make of both prince's
condemnation
of the bbc following on from the
revelations of the dyson report
well i i thought that both their
statements were very
striking indeed we're not just talking
about a much-loved national and
international figure
in the late princess of wales but a
mother as well
and i think that came across this sort
of sense of
family sadness and tragedy and when you
think about it you know if it was any
family the sort of behavior that has
been
uh evidenced in this damning report
raises some very
serious unquestionable questions indeed
sadly for the bbc
does the bbc need a complete overhaul
now
well the report runs to 127 pages it
deals with
some very important aspects of the
conduct not just
of the uh journalists themselves but
actually senior management at the bbc
and decisions that were made
at the time clearly it's going to need
some careful consideration and the
government will do that
soberly and calmly to see what
if anything needs to be done to improve
governance at the bbc
will that be a complete overhaul though
as oliver dowden has actually suggested
yes well uh my colleague the culture
secretary has rightly said that
uh we'll need to look carefully at the
report and consider issues about
governance
i think inevitably that flows from what
lord dyson
has said we'll do it calmly and sensibly
and carefully
uh the bbc is of course our public
service broadcaster
uh freedom of expression and freedom of
speech are clearly at the heart
of what the bbc indeed what sky and
other broadcasters do but there is a
responsibility
that they have uh to the rest of us uh
to
uh families like the royal family in
this instance
and that needs to be taken very
seriously indeed prince harry what went
so far as to say that that interview
contributed
to taking diana's life would you
agree with that assessment well i think
it's difficult for me as an observer to
start to comment about what happened
inside the royal family
i remember the interview very well as
i'm sure you do it was
quite a moment in the life of our
country and indeed it made international
headlines as well and uh
you know i can the statement that he
made indeed that the duke of cambridge
made
you get in those statements you get that
sense of of personal loss
uh and personal tragedy that cannot be
ignored
uh you alluded to the the point before
that this wasn't just a rogue
reporter this is talking about the
leadership at the bbc that needs to be
looked at
well yes when you when you start coping
through the dyson report and indeed
looking at the summary
that that is its focus about what senior
leadership
failed to do and what they did wrong
when it came to the assessment
of the behavior of the uh the team
involved
in the events that led up to the
princess of wales agreeing
to give what became an historic
interview or all of this
is going to make it more difficult for
the bbc to
resist any changes that you might want
to impose on this isn't it
well look i i think that we all need to
uh look at this soberly and calmly uh
clearly the report is damning uh nobody
can get away from that
and i think the first thing will be for
the bbc
to acknowledge that they've apologized
which i think is in a very important
start
but clearly uh all of us uh bearing
that's after the event though isn't it
many years after the event and their own
investigation which was described as
woeful
yeah and i i i think that is right i
think an apology is a start
but i don't think it's the end of it
which is why all of us
looking at its governance looking at the
way it operates
uh a need to uh do that in order to make
sure that this sort of behavior this
sort of thing
doesn't happen again